the push to get the nation's 28 million
children aged 5 to 11 vaccinated has
started and is expected to go into full
swing next week the government has
purchased 65 million doses of the pfizer
vaccine specifically tailored for
children michael george is here this
morning with how these kid-sized doses
are being rolled out nationwide michael
very good news for a lot of parents out
there that's right good morning the food
and drug administration gave the green
light on tuesday and by wednesday
morning parents were lining up to get
their kids vaccinated now while some are
choosing to wait many parents are
relieved they can finally give their
kids some protection from kovid
take a deep breath
and then it will be over in houston
where the health department rolled out
free shots yesterday this boy's mother
was the one brought to tears i've worked
as a nurse for a very long time i've had
staff members get coveted
i've just been so scared so
sorry i'm a little emotional i just
i just wanted them to be safe
karen maribel is a pediatric nurse with
her just vaccinated son sullivan is a
cancer survivor
so
i mean our goal is to never have to be
admitted in the hospital ever again more
than 10 000 under the age of 12 already
received their first shot since
wednesday according to the cdc the
moment that we get the kids vaccinated
this is going to be the end of the
pandemic chicago will close schools
friday to allow families time to
inoculate students mayor lori lightfoot
announced and although there have been
fewer culvert 19 cases in
hospitalization among children the
long-term effects of a pediatric covert
19 case can be serious and lasts for
months nationally just over 58 percent
of all americans are now fully
vaccinated and mandates are mounting
thank you so much los angeles county
yesterday added indoor bars wineries
breweries and nightclubs to places
patrons will need to provide proof of
their vaccinations one guy called us a
communist and started yelling in the bar
you know i just kind of smile okay have
a nice day you know but pushback against
vaccine mandates ratcheted up yesterday
when 11 states filed a lawsuit against
the biden administration's requirement
that workers at large companies be
vaccinated by january 4th otherwise a
company will have to start weekly
testing of those not vaccinated the
looming legal battle comes as case rates
are increasing in some places up here in
the midwest and particularly in michigan
it is climbing right now and as we head
toward thanksgiving
folks who are not vaccinated
are going to be more and more vulnerable
and there could be a new weapon in the
arsenal to treat covet pfizer on friday
said its experimental anti-viral pill
cuts death and hospital rates by 90
percent in high-risk adults pfizer says
it will ask the fda to authorize the
pill as soon as possible jeff
michael thank you very much